the former director of the largest u.s.
stockpile of medical supplies tells us
there is not enough inventory to meet
the needs of the doctors and the nurses
the US has already dipped into the
strategic national stockpile catherine
herridge spoke with Greg Borel about
that
Greg Buell retired in January after 12
years as head of the strategic national
stockpile the nation's eight billion
dollar supply of medical equipment drugs
and protective gear ken the stockpile
support the needs of American hospitals
the u.s. began tapping that lifeline
earlier this month shipping supplies
across the country from government
warehouses their locations kept secret
for national security reasons with
officials providing CBS News this recent
video the stockpiles biggest deficit may
be ventilators an official with Health
and Human Services confirmed to CBS News
there were sixteen thousand six hundred
ventilators before kovat 19 now there
are thousands less as officials
anticipate a surge of new cases another
complication in response to the 2009
h1n1 pandemic the stockpile deployed
nearly 20 million pieces of personal
protective equipment an 85 million n95
mass we didn't protected while the new
stimulus package earmarked 16 billion
dollars for the national stockpile
gorilla says he's still on edge my
concern going forward is it's going to
be hard to prepare for a second
way or for a future need in this area so
while the Supplemental appropriations
Congress has provided a wonderful the
question is how do we sustain that
further investment for the future
in a statement to CBS News a
spokesperson for Health and Human
Services said they've made several
targeted purchases of protective gear
and with additional testing officials
determined some older masks and surgical
gowns are still good to use on the lack
of ventilators the FDA issued an
emergency use authorization that allows
certain devices including anesthesia gas
machines to be modified and used as
ventilators in healthcare settings Tony
whatever it takes Catherine Catherine
thank you very much